des sportifs ultra musclé un rythme
effréné la fièvre du crossfit a gagné le
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
pendant trois jours la structure
accueilli pour la toute première fois le
crossfit french rawdon la compétition a
attiré près de 9000 personnes dans
l'enceinte moitié anglais j'ai fait ce
genre de boulot dans toutes ces pays les
infrastructures ici sont exceptionnelles
comme la flexibilité de l'équipe aussi
nous permettent de concerts on a
construit un stade à l'extérieur on a un
village partenaires sur la compétition
plusieurs catégories tête au programme
des moins de 18 ans plus de 50 ans au
total 540 participants venus de 47 pays
se sont affrontés à travers une dizaine
d'épreuves qui mêlé à la fois force
endurance précision et vitesse
même ma catégorie eric saade très gros
niveau donc ouais ça un honneur d'être
ici c'est vraiment un événement réussi
pour moi c'est le maire événements en
europe qui existe entre autres et où je
pensais pas que ce soit au niveau ça
nous booste même nous les plus petits
pour devenir plus gros et plus fort donc
très très gros niveau c'est très
intéressant
je pensais pas avoir autant de monde ici
et c'est vraiment bien ça montre que
crossfit a beaucoup d'importance
les meilleurs ont remporté un chèque de
dix mille euros et le droit de
participer au crossfit games
l'équivalent de la coupe du monde de la
discipline
vu le succès rencontré cette année les
organisateurs discutent déjà d'un
éventuel retour de l'autre national de
saint quentin en yvelines